will season 17 of the ellen degeneres
show go on without ellen
stars are starting to take sides in
hollywood and ellen was seen for the
first time out and about
since this daytime drama began
how are you going to know when it's the
right time to walk away from daytime
i'll walk away really when i when i stop
having fun the 62 year old talk show
host apparently trying to keep a low
profile amid reports
that claim she is ready to call it quits
feels betrayed by her staff and
has had enough despite all that ellen's
producers are moving ahead with the new
season
a source tells et that the show staff
plan to return to set shooting new
episodes of ellen's show next month
and one of ellen's top producers tweeted
nobody is going off the air
ellen has apologized to staff after a
buzzfeed report claimed
there was a toxic work culture on the
show she suggested high-level producer
changes were imminent
and an internal investigation is
underway
but the hits keep coming this weekend
actress leah thompson
who starred in back to the future backed
up comedian brad garrett's tweet
that bad treatment on the show was
common knowledge leo responded
true story it is so who's sticking up
for ellen
well ellen's wife portia derosi shared
this i stand by ellen image this morning
and jerry o'connell reposted prince
harry's friend polo player
nacho figueres called the show a very
well-run machine
but as of our deadline none of ellen's
other a-list friends like justin bieber
jen aniston reese witherspoon or kristen
bell
have offered their public support as for
who could take over ellen's spot
well there is a new report that late
night host james corden could
but that is unlikely because he has a
long-term deal with cbs
ellen has a deal to stay on the air
through season 19 and a lot of people
think that she wants to get to season 20
sort of hit that milestone but i think
it's anyone's guess if she actually
makes it there
if i'm having fun and no one's watching
i don't care
but if i'm if i'm not having fun and
everyone's watching
then i should walk away